hey youtubers is charlie so yesterday
during my break our chains video asked
you to submit all your questions about
the big WTF change to Jamie's character
and all the other big moments so I
picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question we also
have to give a big high five to Teresa
Harris for winning this week's giveaway
so I'll be reaching out to you on your
channel for details but you basically
want a twenty dollar amazon gift card if
you're finding me for the first time I'm
just doing a weekly game of thrones give
away just as a way to say thank you to
everyone for being so awesome so we have
a lot to talk about and because you know
what happened with Jamie's character was
such a big deal I think I'm gonna focus
on that first so just reminding everyone
please be nice to each other no matter
what your opinion is but it was really
intense so let's get started careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but here we go question
number one bloody desires asks do you
think the way Jamie was during that
scene was out of character considering
his development so far considering he's
saved briand from getting raped before
they cut his hand off so yes George are
Martin actually even commented on the
moment himself he basically said that
because the show brought Jamie back to
King's Landing earlier than normal the
whole dynamic between him and Cersei had
changed in the book version of that
scene Cersei is st. Jamie for the first
time in the crypt and she wants him just
as badly as he wants her but on the show
because jamie has been back for weeks
the whole context had changed and Martin
actually kind of tried to distance
himself from the show the way they
portrayed it by saying that he never
talked to D&D about that scene I think
it's kind of unfortunate because Jamie's
character is supposed to be on something
of a redemptive arc he's trying to be
more like free end and this scene kind
of destroyed that they do have follow-up
scenes next week which hopefully will
spell out a little bit more where the
show is taking jamie this season i think
the other big question that we need to
ask is is did the show intend to do it
more like the books and just mess up in
the practical aspect of filming it and
you know did the actors just change
something on the day you know did it go
down the way they intended it to
question number two valentino asks when
do you think Stannis will march on the
wall so not before Davos follows up on
that letter to the iron bank remember
that scene where the boat passes
underneath the Titan of Braavos in the
trailer I think that's Davos visiting
the bank
the bank has actually become a pretty
big plot point this season remember how
the crown is in super big debt to them
lady Olenna was even talking to Tywin
about it in the second episode he kind
of shrugged it off but it sounds like
Davos is going to use that to get the
money from the iron bank but I'm
actually really interested to see if the
bank becomes a much bigger part of the
story going forward because promises to
the bank you know promissory notes is in
debt has to be paid to the bank
otherwise they will turn around and fund
your enemies question number 3 Steve
sunny asks why is Doran an independent
Kingdom so I actually got a whole bunch
of questions about Dorne and why they
have a prince but not a king and how
they resisted you know Aegon Targaryen
conquests of Westeros so this is kind of
meant to sum up all those things the
reason that Doran has a prince but not a
king is that when Aegon Targaryen
conquered Westeros Dorne used much
smarter military tactics and because of
the desert in the mountains they were
able to drive the Targaryen zout their
tactics just made it so that the
Targaryens couldn't use their dragons
the way they needed to like on all the
other armies of Westeros then by the
time Baelor the Blessed became king he'd
fixed everything remember Tywin actually
mentioned him when he was talking to
Tomin Baylor used a bunch of marriage
pacts to bring door and into the kingdom
but as part of that arrangement each new
ruler of Dorne got to keep the title
Prince so there's only one king of
Westeros but Doran still has a prince
whereas all the other noble houses have
lords and ladies and remember about that
marriage pact thing marcella is actually
betrothed to one of the really young
Martell princes right now question
number 4 series torres asks who is the
king now so thomann is the king if that
wasn't clear from the episode until he's
old enough to make political and policy
decisions though Tywin is effectively
gonna be the ruler tubman will just be a
figurehead until then in the books they
make him sound much much younger the
actor on the show almost looks like a
teenager he was like seven in season one
so he's supposed to be like 10 or 11 now
so they definitely aged him up a lot in
the book all they really let Toman do is
just stamp documents like it's a game
like you would you know give a child
finger paints except that he's
finger-painting the royal seal on like
really important documents which is just
another example of like something really
big
Oh changed question number five Danny
stones asks do you think that
Littlefinger is going to train Sansa to
play the game of thrones no I don't
think she's gonna become like Aria she's
not gonna become a super spy or anything
I do hope that she gets wiser and more
cunning until now the most common
adjective used to describe her has been
sweet as in sweet Sansa she is just kind
of like a leaf being blown around by all
these big forces around her and up to
now she's really just kind of done and
believed whatever anyone is told her
namely little finger so hopefully this
season will finally get to see some sort
of san sebastian tour the closest thing
to it but if you are reading the book
she is a wins a winner POV character so
you know hopefully there'll be some
really awesome Sansa moments then but
I'm not gonna hold my breath question
number 6 Peter Chao asks why are the
cannibals traveling with egrets group so
the thins are just part of the raiding
party that's trying to open that gate at
Castle black it can only be open from
the other side of the wall so Mance
Rayder can't bring his army through
until it's opened and the wildlings
can't open it until they eat through a
lot of pro in the book the thins weren't
relate cannibals but another tribe was
but since there are so many tribes of
Wild links the show just had to kind of
condensed a lot of that stuff I actually
think that for one of my future bonus
videos I'm gonna do something just for
all the different tribes of the
wildlings there's so many of them that
you kind of have to give them their own
video question number 7 Casey asks do
you think the time when is taking Toman
under his wing because he doesn't want
another Joffrey situation so I
definitely think he's aware that Toman
is open to suggestion remember how he
went straight to marriage and heirs he's
all about the Lannister bloodline and
duty to family mostly that the line
continues instead of the birds and the
bees you know with him it's more like
the business in the bees I don't think
that Tywin is necessarily evil I think
he's more like a grumpy Vulcan he has
like this really clear vision for what
he wants his family to be in how he
thinks that the kingdom figures into
that and now that Toman is king he's
found himself in a situation where not a
lot of people are gonna be causing him
problems the big issue with Joffrey was
is that he just made a lot of decisions
without consulting Tywin or he just
flat-out did the opposite the first
really good example of that is whenever
Joffrey beheaded Ned Stark Tywin totally
would not have done that it's actually
kind of what started the war the
five Kings question number eight Chad
more desks why does Alliser thorne hate
Jon Snow mostly because he's a very
petty small man whenever John first came
to the watch Alliser you know who's
mastered arms just mocked him by calling
him Lord snow making fun of the fact
that he was a highborn bastard who ended
up at the Nights Watch which is kind of
like the ultimate chain gang of Westeros
and eventually Jon Snow made fun of him
back and that's when Alistair started
just to outright hate him you know
bullies do not like to be bullied
themselves it's not a very good reason
to hate someone but the book version of
the character is a very petty person
question number 9 gasps to d2 asks do
you think Game of Thrones will feature
any flashbacks so I assume you're
talking about flashbacks to the past the
history of Westeros yes I think bran
will actually see some whenever he
finally meets the three-eyed Raven he'll
probably tell brand his story you know
how he came to be where he is so they'll
have to show something from his past it
just seems too cool not to especially
with that dream sequence they did
whenever brand worked with the tree
actually the next bonus video I'm doing
the bonus video for next Sunday before
episode 4 is gonna be all about the
Bloodraven that was actually the
three-eyed Ravens name back when he was
in Westeros so that'll cover a lot of
history in great detail but I won't be
talking about any of this stuff that's
gonna happen in the future on the show
question number 10 Martin asks do you
feel the hound has become more docile
since teaming up with arya so i
definitely think that aria is rubbing
off on him and that whenever he senses
it he just tries to shake it off as much
as he can like when they were taken in
by the farmer he played along and you
could see that he thought about staying
to help them but then in the morning his
own sense of self loathing just rises up
and he shakes off all the niceness and
just robs the hell out of him I think
that he hates himself so much that
whenever anyone treats him with any kind
of kindness either doesn't believe them
or he treats it with hatred I really do
think that aria is getting tired of him
though so I wonder how much longer it's
gonna continue they have kind of a
temporary truce that's been going on
because Arya knows that the Hound can
help her and the Hound knows that she's
worth money to someone and one last
bonus question side effect asks how big
of a role will mark gatiss have so I
don't think it's going to be Mycroft big
if that's what you're wondering he's
playing someone who works for the iron
bank of
vose I haven't seen him on the show yet
so I think we will see him when we do
travel to Braavos Davos is gonna have to
borrow a ton of money to get Stannis
that army so eventually we will see that
place there was actually a pretty cool
shout out for the gold company so he
might actually be using that money to
hire them as a mercenary army which
actually reminds me even if the show
doesn't end up going down that route I'm
planning on doing bonus videos for the
golden company and the second son's
because both those mercenary groups has
really interesting histories so thank
you so much for submitting questions
these are always a lot of fun to do I'm
sure the Jamie debate is gonna continue
to go on I think we'll get some more
answers whenever the next episode airs
but remember my next bonus video is
going to be about the Bloodraven be sure
to subscribe to get it and feel free to
leave me suggestions for other bonus
videos in the comments below so right
now click here to get my bonus video for
the history of marine and slavers Bay
and click here to get my review the
episode thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow high fives
you